so there are some major mistakes
that we can make on youtube that hurt
our views and the growth
of our channel and so i'm so excited for
this video because i'm gonna be joined
by
heather torres the uh one of the content
creators on the think media team and
she's going to be breaking down three of
the biggest mistakes and how to fix them
when it comes to being on camera one of
these is causing people to jump off your
video and she's going to show you how to
fix that and another one of these
is going to help you be able to make
deeper connections with the viewer
so that they can become a subscriber and
ultimately that your channel can grow
faster and so heather uh this is the
think marketing q a show i'm so fired up
how you doing today
i am so excited because man these are
three mistakes that i've personally made
and now
after making videos that have millions
of views on them i'm like
oh man i could do better so i'm excited
to give these to
people um for their videos to make
better videos well we're going to jump
right into it and so smash the like
button and let us know where you're
watching from on whatever platform
and today's episode is actually brought
to you by our free
7-day youtube influence challenge
heather's going to tell us more about
that
and then jump into these three tips and
then after that we're gonna do a little
bit of q a
with some of you coming on the show and
so heather
tell us all about this challenge yeah
you know the youtube influence challenge
uh it's a seven day free challenge that
we've put out because
we understand that where the world is
right now and maybe where you are in
business or
maybe wanting to shift into
understanding the online space
we wanted to create an opportunity where
we would teach our
seven step process that we teach inside
of our two thousand dollar course
we want to teach that to you for free so
we've put together this seven
day challenge where you can join it with
creators and entrepreneurs and
purpose-driven people from all around
the world
and we're walking you through things
like how to reverse engineer your
channel
and how to rank your videos so they get
discovered in search and how you can
grow and make money for the mission
by using youtube you know youtube is the
vehicle
that really helped uh my family and
sean's family and other people on the
think media team
have financial freedom and that was
because of this seven-step system
that has allowed us to grow a youtube
channel to over a million subscribers
and help thousands of entrepreneurs go
further with their channels so i'm
excited if you've not
joined the challenge yet you can go to
tubeinfluence.com
i'll tell you a little bit more about it
towards the end but let's go ahead and
jump into
these three mistakes that you're
probably making on camera
right now and how to stop making these
mistakes and
mistake number one is not being prepared
not being prepared is one of the biggest
mistakes
we see creators making now what does
this mean do you need to be scripting
every single youtube video
does this mean that you need to uh line
by line know what you're going to say
not necessarily this just means what's
the video for
really analyzing what you're doing
before you press
record and i know as a creator that
sometimes you just have to push past the
fear and get the video going
but the best videos on youtube are
videos that have been prepared
that have been thought through that have
some cohesion
to them how is it starting where is it
going you know the best movies that i
love to watch are movies that
start with some suspense or have a
problem and then
that actor has to go through this whole
journey
to come to a conclusion well youtube
video is exactly the same and one of the
mistakes that a lot of creators are
making on camera
is they're not actually being prepared
for their videos and i love this quote
by uh benjamin franklin he said by
failing to prepare
you are preparing to fail so if you're
wondering why aren't my videos getting
any views why is no one watching my
videos
well i want to turn it around and ask
you are you prepared
for the content that you're creating are
you coming at youtube
as seeing it as something that you're
putting out into the world you're
putting art out into the world
are you prepared are you just grabbing
your phone and just recording a video
so really be thinking about that uh that
is mistake number one mistake number two
is
not looking at the camera and oh man
as a content creator i have made this
mistake
looking at this lens talking to a lens
it doesn't feel normal but let me tell
you when you connect with someone on the
other side of the camera
that is so valuable uh people actually
remember
what you are saying more when you make
eye contact with them there was actually
a study that at sterling
university where they took participants
onto a video call
and they had them talk to one another
and they found that there was a 40
retention rate because people looked at
each other
on the video call they made eye contact
on the video call now with the world
that we're in right now
video is everything and so by mastering
this skill
is a huge advantage for you you're
creating these videos you're putting
time and effort into them
why not connect with your audience and i
know it feels
so awkward to talk to that little tiny
camera
and i make this mistake sometimes when
i'm making videos
i want to look at the screen i want to
see what i look like to make sure that
this
looks okay but when you actually look at
the
the camera when someone's watching it on
the other side
they're able to then connect with you so
right now i'm looking directly into your
eyes
i'm looking into my webcam and you're
looking directly into my eyes but when i
shift down here to read
you can see that we've now lost that
connection but when i come back up here
you and i are then connected again
remember when you are
making youtube videos you're making it
for one person
you're talking to someone who's watching
it on their phone on a car ride
or they're on their way uh they're
they're sitting at their house watching
it on their tv you're watching it with
one person so make eye contact with your
audience and this was
like i said a huge mistake that i made
because it's uncomfortable it feels
awkward
but when you start to watch your videos
back and you notice when your eyes
shift and you lose contact you're losing
the ability to connect with your
audience
and the third mistake that we see
content creators making on video is
being
way too long-winded let me tell you let
me ask you a question tell me in the
chat
have you watched a video yes or no where
someone started on video and they go
hey guys welcome back to my channel it's
been so long
since i've been here and you know i had
to take my dog to the vet
and it was just it was so much like time
and i haven't
wanted to make videos but like school is
getting crazy or that
like stop can we just stop that
is not a way that you start a video you
start a video with a hook
you start a video with a way that's
going to draw your audience
in and you want to do that because you
want them to keep watching your video
you want them to be someone who watches
to the end of the content
and if you're adding too much fluff into
your video
that is going to have people drop off
and move on to the next thing
you know we have such a short attention
span that if we're not getting the
information that we want right away
we'll go someone else to find it so one
of our mentors and friends chalene
johnson says be brief be bright be fun
and be
done you want to make sure that when
you're creating youtube videos
that you are creating videos that are
snappy that you're creating videos that
keep people engaged throughout the whole
things maybe they have some jump cuts to
them
when you're talking you want to make
sure that you're enunciating your words
you want to make sure that when you're
giving your presentation online whether
you're making a youtube video to teach
someone something
or you're sharing something personal in
your daily life depending on what type
of videos you're creating
you just want to make sure that you're
not adding all the fluff right you want
to make sure that your videos are brief
they're bright they're fun and then be
done
and let someone move on to the next
video one of the mistakes
content creators make is they go so
long-winded in one video
that they could have made 10 videos
instead of one so i want you to think
the next time you're creating a video
and you're in the
the recording process things that you
think to yourself and say
is this information relevant to what i'm
doing is
the thing i'm saying right now just kind
of trailing off because i don't know how
to end this sentence
or is this actually going to give a
punctuation a period
to this thought so as you're making your
content make sure you're not making
those three
mistakes on video and i want to share
with you and let you know
that we actually over on the tube
influence challenge
tonight i'm actually going to be sharing
four more critical mistakes that content
creators are making
and how to get over the enemies that are
holding you back for making the best
content possible well i hope those three
mistakes are valuable to you
and that you can use those to not make
them in your next video
i'm excited to get into some q a today i
have sean cannell on with me
we're going to be pulling you on uh here
but if you have not signed up yet for
the
tube influence challenge you want to
make the youtube influence challenge
excuse me
you want to go to tubeinfluence.com
sign up for that free challenge and walk
through the next five
days with us tonight as well as
two sessions per day that are completely
free
that you can learn how to dominate on
youtube and grow your channel
get views make income and make a
difference in the world
well sean i am excited to get into some
of the q a
for people who are coming on but sean
real quick what have you loved about the
challenge
so far with over 40 000 people who are
part of this challenge
how does it make you feel as kind of the
leader of this movement of creators
right now yeah heather i think uh
amazing training by the way and the
challenge has been amazing and i think
the big word for me is community
i think that especially with what's
happening in the world right now it
could be
so we're so isolated a lot of us are
locked down a lot of us maybe saw
softening on local lockdowns and then
we're
home again and we're going out less and
so there can be that feeling i know for
me
um the last time we my wife and i were
in church was
march at the beginning of march and we
love to see friends and family and even
you guys i know we live in the same city
las vegas
and then the lockdown happened and it
was it wasn't until last weekend
in a smaller number of people with all
wearing masks that we actually finally
went back it was like eight months
and so i bet a lot of us can relate to
maybe feeling disconnected or isolated
and like you're like man i just wanted
to go kind of back to how it was before
and obviously online and virtual
experiences
don't replace those in-person
interactions but what's powerful about
the challenge is a group of people
that are coming together and there's so
many there's friendships happening
there's connections happening
we're asking in the private facebook
group people's different niches and
they're like oh i'm in that niche too
like let's stay connected
let's collab and that we're seeing with
the power of stream yard
and online things like zoom and youtube
live that we can connect
and that's why we love doing these live
shows i mean it's cool to see jennifer
and misty here and jimmy and penny
and dimitri and over on youtube becca
and jessica like we just appreciate you
and our goal
is to try to create as much community as
possible and it's just been so inspiring
to see
that synergy and momentum of a group of
like-minded people
that really want to build a high profit
and high
impact youtube channel this year even in
the midst
of these crazy times and so it's been
absolutely amazing and
um really quick before we get into q a
um
if you want to join there's a link and
here's the deal like
when if you're going to come on we it's
ideal if you actually are hardlined in
or you have really good wi-fi
if you have a setup and some decent
lighting and decent audio because if
we're going to pull you on the show we
just want to make sure that like
um the camera's not shaky and that like
it's
uh it's just got some good technical
aspects to it
and then i wanted to ask uh have a kind
of riff on one question that i think
will add value on this topic
someone asked how long should my videos
be and that's a really great question
heather
when it comes to someone starting out on
youtube how long do you think their
content should be
yeah this is a question that we do get
quite a bit and
one of the things we recommend is to
make videos that are
shorter than 10 minutes why well because
someone's just getting to know you and
it gives them
the option if you have say four
10-minute videos
they could go 40 minutes deep with you
on four different
videos versus one video for 40 minutes
it's a commitment right it's like dating
your first date probably isn't going to
last
four hours maybe it is but i i did not
go on my first date for four hours we
met for coffee
i went we had coffee together and then i
bounced i was like i'm out that was fun
right and so by making shorter videos
you're able to go on more
dates with people it allows them to get
to know your personality better rather
than it being just
one super long video now i think another
great reason for making it 10 minutes
or less is for you as the content
creator as you are starting to build
this muscle of creating videos
if you're jumping into youtube creating
30 40
one hour long videos that actually is
probably going to slow your process
down because not only do you have to
film that content you then have to edit
that content and one of the biggest
things we see
as uh creators having difficulties is
getting past that editing
process it takes forever to edit a video
sometimes
so if you can make a video short and
punchy and get right to the point
like the video i just did i mean i
shared three tips
i could have shared all seven right here
i could have made this an hour long
training
but i shared three tips in about 10
minutes and we got through that content
it just allows people to get to know you
it can build a bond with your audience
and
it can also help you with your retention
rate which is very important to youtube
means
how long does someone stay on your video
and watch if your video is 40 minutes
long
and they only make it 10 minutes in well
that's a low retention rate
but if you have four videos that are at
10 minutes and people make it
seven minutes long well that is a 70
retention rate
so you want to be playing the game of
youtube which means how long can you
keep people on the platform
watching as many videos as possible so
how long should your videos be when you
start out
10 minutes or less and then as you grow
an audience and as you want to create
more content and as you build the muscle
of creation
then you can start making videos that
are longer
so strong and we're going to jump on to
a couple guests i'm excited because
we've got
aiden back on the show he was on coffee
with kennel just the other day
aiden i know you have a question about
instagram and i'm excited for heather's
wisdom on that as well
but my man um how what have you been
thinking about the challenge so far and
i now i'm getting to know aiden because
of the challenge because of coffee with
kennel
11 year old entrepreneur runs an agency
on a second youtube channel crushing it
at 11 i wasn't doing what aiden was
doing
bro what have you been getting out of
the youtube influence challenge
first of all i want to say make sure to
trust them in this challenge because
even now like sean said in the past if
you followed him for a very long time
he's a college dropout but just because
you might not be able to afford to go to
college doesn't mean you can't be smart
and knowledgeable
and so uh like i said the challenge has
been
absolutely amazing i've been able to
grow
my channel as well i've been able to get
in contact with some young entrepreneurs
like myself
i actually just got in contact with a 14
year old entrepreneur that
does not live locally to me but i've
been able to get in contact with him to
see what kind of things he's doing to
connect with his audience
and we're just going back and forth to
be able so i can
grow my audience there and he can grow
his audience so we're helping each other
out
i love that aiden learning how to
network early on and let me tell you
the relationships that you have are so
important so i love that you're taking
that and valuing that
and really collaborating with people
aiden thanks for being on the show today
what question do you have for us so my
question is how can i grow
my business through instagram because i
know that
um you have there's things like you can
promote cost money but what are some
free ways on instagram that i can grow
my channel
why don't you take it first one yeah
that's a great question and i think uh
a couple things is it's awesome that we
have your account
brought up here and the first thing
you're already taking action you know
you've already got that momentum going
i would say um a couple things that i
would recommend
is at this point um aiden i want you to
think about
how can this instagram account add value
to the people that are following you
now all of us need to decide when it
comes to our youtube channels or our
instagram account
um yes our instagram might be giving
people
insight into our life like i love that
you posted the battle station because
we're having people post their battle
stations for the challenge and that's
where you get your work done
and that you're being a part of the
challenge and by the way it's crazy you
just hit
a milestone during the youtube challenge
that's awesome congrats on
1500 views but again this is your result
right this is something that
you achieved this is your setup every
post you want to think about you want to
answer this question ask this question
this goes for everybody watching
wherever
on any platform what value will
what value will this post add to the
audience
what value does my instagram account add
to the viewer
to the person who could follow me why
should someone follow me on instagram
and a lot of us
which is kind of like just our friends
and family
on instagram we post like our kids and
like what we're doing and like
stuff about us and selfies of us that's
like kind of a me centered instagram
doesn't have to be bad but it's probably
never going to grow
and impact people the alternative is
what we grew into aiden right
and think media and i had to make this
shift myself and and our instagram is
just my personal instagram but we really
shifted to start using it for business
and i like that you use that word
i'm so inspired that you use that word
11 years old you're like how do i grow
my business
like i love that you're thinking that
way and
what if you see what we shifted here
like think about this win this this is a
giveaway
to the audience this is a instagram tv
that's actually teaching how to shoot
b-roll even this is again a fun
if you will picture of us and the think
media team
but it also is an invitation to the
challenge
and then even if we potentially post
maybe something like this again
an invitation to our challenge that's
what we're mainly promoting now
a lot of times here's again kind of
motivational maybe inspirational
but hopefully it adds value to the
viewer don't get trapped by conspir
comparison your youtube channel your
business your call
on your life is going to be different
than what you see others doing your
journey is going to be different
so put your head down and work on what
you're called
to do so that i'm talking to the viewer
and trying to add
value to the viewer even this again
hopefully adding some value the
aesthetic is something to think about
but also the caption rise and grind it's
a new day full of new opportunities
and i really as maybe people that have
connected with our brand i like to be
motivational inspirational try to be
encouraging
so i'm saying starve your fears and feed
your faith i'm speaking to
the followers to the community to people
saying hey zig ziglar reminds us that
fear has two meetings
forget everything and run or face
everything and rise
you were built for battle and it's kind
of like a monday motivation
type of post so what i would think about
with your channel is be asking
how can you make just like a youtube
channel kind of have a singular value
proposition which you already do
media with aiden really clear and start
shifting
i think it's great to celebrate your
milestones but what i would want to do
is maybe celebrate a milestone
every 10th post and think about posts
like here's a quick
diy hack for how i made i made it so my
mic doesn't fall down
like here's a quick tip for how you and
think about adding value to the audience
that's sort of the
general thesis of winning on social
media in general
thank you so much for that that was
amazing
and um i actually
um want to say thank you um
all of the tips you guys have gave me
have been super powerful
i actually did purchase the youtube
starter kit
and so um i've already been able
to write down like 15 video ideas and
it's been able to help me
and i've been writing down these like
from the youtube challenge
and the starter kit combined have been
able to help me
amazing aiden well i'm so excited for
the rest of the challenge for you
we have so many great sessions coming up
i want you to take this tip that sean uh
just gave you and apply it because i
know you're an
action taken our community people right
now in the comments are like i want to
be aided when i grow up
so keep being a part of this community
aiden you're bringing such
light and i just want to encourage you
to uh just keep
going okay thank you awesome thanks
aiden for joining us today
man if you're getting value out of
today's think marketing q a
show hey hit the like button and maybe
share it with somebody hit that share
button on facebook or on youtube maybe
tell somebody about the stream
if you're watching this on youtube make
sure you're subscribed and uh this
week's think marketing
podcast episode we're still working some
things out with it but it's still coming
and every tuesday we typically drop a
fresh episode
of the think marketing podcast which is
a video podcast that's
on the youtube channel as well as all
the audio platforms
spotify google plus i encourage you go
back and binge
that and then today's episode if you're
curious what's aidan talking about
it's the the free youtube challenge
we're actually right in the middle
middle of this if you happen to be
watching this on the replay
you can still get in on this thing this
thing is only we're on day two
it's seven days long we're taking sunday
off to rest
and so it's really you still got another
six
days to like be in the group take full
advantage the challenge is 100
free so check a link in the description
or actually in the facebook comments
if you want to join that or just go to
tubeinfluence.com
arion iran is that how i say your name
basic indian boy
my man what's your question man where
are you coming from uh
india i'm guessing yeah
yeah the audio is we can't really hear
uh
maybe is it you got to connect up the
bluetooth to the oh there you go
can you read me yeah a little bit better
go for it
it's like super sketchy like we want to
give you the best advice possible but
can't really hear you
um do me a favor we'll put you in the
back we might be able to bring you back
on
uh but uh try to get that audio locked
up whether it's the blue bluetooth audio
or the on camera audio or
anything but appreciate you and as you
say
ask your question in our chat in our
back end chat that we're on and we'll
make sure to get that answered for you
okay
yeah yeah actually yeah if you haven't
posted it back there we'll go in the
private chat here in streamyard
appreciate you bro
awesome and hey that's just a good
reminder for those of us
that um if you ever want to come on a
think marketing q a show it happens
every two weeks
every other week and then we do a show
called coffee with kennel that also
happens every other week um in the
future we'd love for you to join at the
various times we're streaming
just like we had eight and on and
whenever possible try to just be on a
solid connection solid audio just makes
it
you know you know we'll bring we'll try
to bring on whoever but that
if you have decent lighting decent audio
all those kind of things
um and and a good setup that really
helps us and so we've got
sam from anderson lane sam how's it
going
unmute your mic and let us know where
you're watching from
i am watching from woods cross utah
and my kids are in the background so
hopefully you don't hear them
but yeah i am a mom vlogger
i've been working on my channel kind of
as a side job for
three years just went over 500 subs was
super excited about that
and but i'm kind of after watching all
of this
and i have the i purchased the
the what is it the package that you guys
have
um and i went through all that before
this challenge actually started
and now i'm thinking of re totally
vamping my channel
and going into a completely different
niche
and it's kind of scary so
what do you guys have any tips or ideas
for that
what niche do you want to move into sam
so i'm
i love if you can see i've got like a
couple of travel videos on there and
that's
where my passion is people ask me
questions about it all the time
but they also do like diy stuff all the
time people are always asking those
things so
i'm trying to figure out like you guys
were talking about yesterday
where i should really put my focus into
like
what's gonna help me get to that end
result that i want to be able to
make a living off of my channel
eventually and fully put this into
like full drive and make this not a
part-time gig but a full-time gig
so moving from mommy blogger to travel
yeah okay and what type of travels
specifically
so traveling with kids or still because
obviously i'm a mom
that's where my knowledge is that's what
i want to share that's what people ask
me about
and so i still want to have that mommy
niche
but take it more to the travel
genre amazing well i think uh
one thing sam is that that is a viable
viable
market there is so many things um that
one you can review
you don't have to go anywhere you could
just be like reviewing pack and plays
that you can take with you in your car
you could be doing travel um packing
tips like
if you want to switch niches um i
actually see it more as
diving in more into what you're already
doing
because you're already hitting the mom
market
you're just making a slight shift and
this brings
up uh madeleine mult who is
nolan one of the content creators here
at think she started in the lifestyle
space and she was kind of making videos
like you know uh
come with me throughout my day they're
an adorable
young married couple living in la like i
want to be her when i grow up type of
thing
and she was making these videos and we
said madeline
in order for you to break through we
need you to be in a
niche like you got to pick a space do
you you want to do makeup do you want to
do um married tips like what do you want
to do and she's like i love
thrifting and she said do i need to
start a whole new channel and we said no
you're already hitting the target market
that you want to hit
all you need to do is start to make
content that fits in the context
of the niche that you're trying to hit
people are not searching day in the life
of cute girl in la
people are searching thrifting tips for
goodwill but she's able to make it
lifestyle
form but still deliver value so i think
you could actually
start making this pivot on your channel
and
maybe you lose some subscribers because
they're like well actually i really
wanted your cooking tips or actually i
really liked your cleaning things that
you were doing
that's okay because you now have
direction of where you want to go and
that doesn't mean you can't do those
things in the future
but now that you have a plan sam now
that you're like i actually really
am passionate about travel you're
already hitting the target market it'd
be different if you're like
i want to go from talking to moms to
talking to men in their 40s about dating
okay well
okay that's definitely different you're
you're just saying
hey i actually just want to narrow in
into the type of topic i'm talking about
to moms now i understand that this
probably isn't the best travel
season right so how do you work around
that here's a couple things
locally in your area if you as things
start to open up
here's what i'd recommend become a
tourist in your own area and give tips
to people on that
so you don't necessarily even have to go
anywhere it's like how to experience
um you're in utah right
where can you go hiking with kids where
can you
like what do i need to look for when i'm
going to a hotel
how do i pack what um safety things like
thinking about all the things
moms are thinking about when they're
starting to travel that's
what the that's the type of content that
they're looking for and so what i want
you to do also sam is survey your
audience
say hey on your next trip what are the
five to ten things you're thinking about
you're you're gonna get information from
people that you're like i didn't even
know people thought about that that's so
easy
and the reason for that sam is because
you're probably already an expert at it
and you don't know
that they're still worried about how
many snacks
should they give their kids you know
like what's the best snack at disneyland
i don't know does that make sense like
you're like of course i know that
doesn't everyone know that you can get
two for one if you go to this little
shop over here and you do that like
does that make sense so you're just
narrowing down into the type of content
you're creating and i want you to love
on those moms i want you to give them
the best advice
i want you to review all the travel
things that they can
practically buy like everything from
babies to teenagers
what do they need to have in their car
on the plane all those things
because you then become the travel
expert for moms
who want to take their kids on trips
thank you guys so much this is awesome
and that makes it a lot less scary for
me
because i don't have to like totally
revamp and start over i can just kind of
transition exactly and you can change
your change your header if you want to
i've changed my header like five times
like you can change those things that's
okay
it's the content where is she meeting
you she's meeting you
on the five travel hacks with a newborn
i would need if i'm a new mom and it's
my first time traveling
believe me i am searching that and
you're like i've already traveled i have
five kids i have three how many kids you
have sam
i have three yeah see i have three kids
i know how to travel with a newborn
one on my hip i know how to drive and
put the thing the pacifier in the back
at the same time you know like
i got those tricks you gotta teach her
those tricks
all right thanks so much guys this is
awesome
awesome thanks sam for being on
appreciate you sam
man awesome heather just bring in the
sharp and specific advice hey listen
um if you're getting an aha moment if
you're getting some clarity for your
strategy your channel
um drop that in the comments section
what is maybe an idea from today's
training and stream that you're gonna
change an update on your channel maybe
it's a video idea maybe it's just
something you're gonna fix when it comes
to being on camera
maybe it's a strategy pivot and i think
we're gonna have time for another
question here
um but hit the like button lightly if
you're getting value out of today's
training
and i'm fired up because we have a tree
coming on man it's awesome to see the
battle station
um love love the guitar hey where are
you watching from where are you
well i'm from brazil i live in the south
of brazil in a farm
you know i'm a farmer and i have this
youtube channel teaching people how to
make videos you know
just like people who are never
like use that camera before some things
like this
and because i work with video i've been
trying to help new
people that have like small business or
well i think that my english will not be
enough to try to share with you
or that i'm trying and maybe my accent
is a little bit strong
but like someone who has a small
business and never
did videos before so i'm trying to help
these people
and first of all i just want to thank
you guys because i've been following you
for a very long time and i've been
learning a lot with you guys and
one point that i want to bring to this
conversation that
i was looking to my analytics a few days
ago
and 95 percent of all my audience
are guys are men
and i don't know why but like uh
i'm trying to bring to teach this for
like girls too
like you you guys do and
since i saw that on my analytics i've
been
trying to think how to reach more
like girls women who want to learn how
to make
videos and like i'm on
only reaching five percent of
of all my audience as a woman
and please heather help me
give me some advice well i'll jump into
that piece
uh and i have a question for you one
dimitri thank you for serving
the uh are you teaching in portuguese
yeah
yeah thank you for serving the
portuguese community
because here's the thing we're making
content in english and we're really
serving
mainly american european i mean we do go
into south america and a little bit into
asia
but we are restricted by being able to
teach in other languages because i don't
speak another language so dimitri i want
i want you to say thank you for teaching
this content in portuguese because it's
needed the
youtube is for everyone and
understanding how to create video
in a native language is highly important
so
i want to honor you first for stepping
out and into that
and i want to ask you dimitri um why
why do you feel the need to need to
pivot into reaching women is it so you
can reach more people or because you see
a need in that
in that uh in that gender or community
i see i really see a need you know i i
had some
customers some clients uh years ago even
not so many times ago that was woman who
had like small business
small stores you know and i went to help
them say
have you done like uh instagram stories
and they say
no i never did that do you know how to
do instagram stories
and they um i don't so i think that this
is a need
you know and i want to reach more women
because i
i believe that i can help them on how to
make videos for their business yes and
i think this is the point for me i see a
need and i see sometimes that
women they they are not so connected
with
all this kind of technology sometimes
you know
i think that men they like they like
more this kind of thing
and what i see this is a need and
especially for
who has a small business youtube
and video it's a great tool so it's
it would be a really great opportunity
to help them
to make videos for the for their
business perfect
i love that thank you so much for your
heart in wanting to connect to small
business owners and to really
teach them technology um i think that
there
is uh um there is a part though
that even though you are a man teaching
doesn't mean that a woman won't resonate
with you it's just so far where you are
with your channel i know we brought your
channel up and where you are
in your subscribers and what that looks
like that you're just
right now you're just reaching more men
and that's okay
you can be sharing this content with
other creator or with other business
owners like women
um but it doesn't actually actually mean
because you're only you you are
currently at uh 700 700 subscribers
as you start to create more content just
because you're reaching one demographic
right now
doesn't mean it won't spill over into
other demographics
and one of the things that i think um
that's great is you are including yep
right there sean you're including
visuals of women
in your content which is a great thing
to do
because that allows them to be able to
connect with you
you can also um sean does this really
well he
uh he taps into an emotional side
which allows him to connect with women
on a higher level
because he's not like aggressively male
dominant energy coming at you which
i'm okay like grant cardone aggressive
male content coming
at me but i i know that because i am in
that stage
but because he is um because he is more
emotionally in tune
with the feeling of what it's like to be
a creator he connects
with women on a different level um so so
that dimitri could be one tip for you is
to be thinking about the words that
you're saying
so the the business owners that you're
helping what is she saying
is she saying that's too much i'm i'm
scared of this tech
if you actually say those exact words on
camera she's gonna be like
oh my gosh he he knows me he's speaking
my language if you're like here's the
thing
you don't actually need to use all the
gear let's just start making instagram
stories
let's start there because i get it
sometimes you're scared to get on camera
that's that's probably what she's saying
to herself
that's happening a lot i'm afraid of
cameras and things like this
exactly so making a whole series on how
to not be afraid to get on camera how to
be confident on camera
could start to attract that audience now
i would also recommend dimitri that you
start as a as a business owner teaching
this in portuguese
maybe offering classes and sending that
to female business owners in your area
and saying hey my name is dimitri
um i've had this much experience i'm
going to be teaching this free
online class where i'm going to teach
you how to get over the fear of getting
on camera so you can get more customers
in your
in your business because what do they
want they're business owners
they need more customers so you're
speaking to them you're going to get
over a fear
and you're going to give them a result
and through
that you're going to start to hear the
language that they're saying the words
that they're saying the marketing that
they're actually
saying and then you start to tie that
into the content that you're creating
and the second thing is is i would study
what we're doing
what vanessa lao is doing what sunny
leonard doozy is doing what
um what katherine manning is doing
they're all creating content around
youtube in english and i would recreate
that in
in portuguese because that's nice
there's a market for it
yes any other tips for him sean yeah i
was just gonna say
uh this is such a a relevant topic
for everybody watching because there
might be
certain demographics you want to reach
into in this case dimitri
wants to connect with more of a women
audience it could be connecting with
a younger generation or an older
generation one of the best things
you can do is get feedback meaning
get someone in your life it might be
over zoom but if it could actually be in
your life to give you honest
the key word is honest helpful critical
feedback about your content
so heather torres is one of the most
amazing things that happened to think
media for a lot of reasons
but one of the reasons was bringing in a
different perspective
for example dmitry exactly what she just
said in terms of like
being way more empathetic to even maybe
where a female mentality is coming from
and so guys in relationships would know
this in fact girls that are in a
relationship with a guy
would probably say this he just doesn't
get it he's so disconnected
he just doesn't understand come on
ladies can you relate to that he just
you know he like he just doesn't
understand me i don't think he knows
where i'm coming from he just doesn't
listen
well that actually shows us like there's
good books like
men are from mars women are from venus
or or
my wife and i did marriage counseling
and our marriage counselor taught us
you know men [ __ ] speak blue she taught
me
women speak pink so what you need to do
is start translating pink
and and sonia what you start need to do
is you you need to like
take your pink thoughts and turn them
into blue language and i'd be like
oh i get it i'll do that for you honey
you know or whatever and so
there's something about growing in
empathy and self-awareness but
feedback is one of the best ways that
that can happen
so having a heather on the team or in a
lean listen
having alina on the team gives us
different
cultural feedback you want if we want to
be more diverse content creators you
want to be getting perspectives from
different ages
different uh backgrounds different
genders
different perspectives different
ethnicities
because a lot of times i i actually
really believe that
you know there's so much division
especially in america here right now
but it's not that i think that people
are bad people we just live in bubbles
and we don't have a lot of empathy for
people that are different from us so i'm
kind of taking this to a bigger level to
add value to our whole community
but man when you need to when you want
to rub shoulders with other people
like for example i'm 36 and i want to
keep the think media brand
young right and so we've got nolan on
the team i think he's 23.
and so um he's over a decade younger
than me and we're trying
to get like we're trying to get some
consulting from aiden
because aiden's 11. and so there's it's
gonna be very difficult for me to get
into
that mentality that's why i want my
world to be big i want
i want my relationship network to be big
i want my friendships to be big
i want my community to be big and i want
to be open to diverse perspectives i'm
blowing this up way past
just you know reaching females but if
you reverse engineer what is your goal
like again man i'm like i think that's a
cool way to dress
and then even omar who's a few years
like about half a decade younger
and has way better fashion taste he's
like nah bro this is what and if we're
open to feedback
for if we want to stay contemporary if
we want to connect with people we need
to be
talking with people and be willing for
them to say
yeah that kind of came across kind of
just
kind of like heather said kind of just
like a real
real manly kind of like kind of
insensitive
cool if that's who you want to reach and
what it ultimately comes down to
is if you're like some people even in
politics and you only care about
connecting with your base
well then you maybe only communicate in
one way but if you want to become
a communicator that can connect with
different types of people
then we have to be in a journey of being
humble being willing to learn
and being able to get feedback and so
let me just land the plane by saying
is there some women in your life that
you could have watch your content and
give you tips
is there could you do a show like this
and bring on
a co-host aka a
translator like one of them that's one
of the most powerful things about
heather is sometimes omar
and nolan and sean and tony the four of
us will sit together and start talking
about cameras and she'll go
time out guys you just said three terms
i have no idea what you're talking about
so thank god she's in the room because
it's one of the reasons we've been able
to grow and think media
because we go oh we don't know what we
don't know we don't know how to
necessarily connect
or what if you told she'll help me make
my talks better
you know if you tell this story or that
part that you told there
women are going to be able to relate to
that more and i'll be like i don't know
i'm just speaking blue over here
give me some pink tips heather you know
what i'm saying so
all of this can really help us level up
as communicators but i think that could
actually serve you
when it comes to connecting with women
start talking to women have them watch
your videos
and ask how they can level them up and
consider even if you did a show like
this you might have somebody in your
life it might be six months or even a
year later
where they could sort of be the bridge
because there's no doubt about it
shout me out in the comments number one
if you're a heather fan but number two
if if like you've noticed the think
media brand i believe has gotten
stronger
than anyone who's on their own you know
one can put a thousand to flight two can
put ten thousand to flight
we are a little more rounded at this
point with the fact that we're
representing both genders
even on this very stream so we can kind
of hit things from multiple perspectives
i just think that expands our world and
gives us the power
of connecting at a wider level
great thank you so much uh you said
something that i would ask you if that
was a
good idea to have someone with me like
my wife
helping me you know doing something like
this
i would ask you but you gave me the
answer and heather i just wanted to
say tell you that my wife would love to
follow you
we have four kids and we are preparing
ourselves to do homeschooling next year
amazing i will take some of your videos
and i will translate to her she
understands a little bit of english but
it's not enough to watch a full video
you know but thank you guys for all the
tips
uh love you guys i've been following you
following you for a very long time
and that's it let's go thank you so much
i will try to bring
my my pink
make your blue pink yeah yeah make my
blue pink yeah
thank you thank you appreciate you
dimitri thanks so much
heather that was a that's a good little
little conversation i'm glad dimitri
came on and that was that was a powerful
thing and it's been crazy the journey
and i just want to acknowledge
you and thank you for not just your
character and your content
and uh the impact you make on our team
obviously on our community so many
people are like i'm a heather fan
and and just you're just a really
incredible person but i think that again
one of the things we agree on is just
the strength and diversity
um and we believe in honor team and
unity in a diversity we don't all think
the same
we don't all believe the same things but
we believe actually that even in
diversity we can be unified and really
be stronger together
by having empathy and really
understanding each other better
and that iron sharpens iron there's no
question about it that heather is
iron sharp like proven
in her craft and her content in her life
and her character
and and and we each bring different
things to the team as well as the entire
team
and i think that that just makes us
stronger yeah thank you so much sean i
i just i think it's so amazing that we
even have the opportunity as content
creators to be able to speak to our
audience right to be able to reach more
people
and thank you so much for just being a
great leader who um
allows other people to have platform uh
to help people
to um learn more and i love how you said
with two of us we can do so much more
so thank you so much that was really
that was a really great conversation i'd
love to dive maybe into a podcast about
that so let us know
if you'd want more um more if you have
more questions
about that like you want to reach more
in the demographics how do you start to
do that
how can men and women work together you
know all of those things are really
important and um thank you so much for
all the heather fans
in the audience you guys are awesome and
my heart just blew up when he said
they're gonna homeschool their kids if
you know
i am number one in homeschooling so um
that was really awesome
and i think what's great about youtube
sean is that
even though you know you and i were
we're in las vegas we're in two
different parts of las vegas and
sometimes we can think that youtube
really is only for english speakers
or that youtube is only for this type of
person
and what i love about what dimitri is
doing is he's taking something that's so
critical for the world to learn
and he's bringing it into his own
culture and i think that if you have
something different like dimitri does
he's telling this
he's teaching the same things we're
teaching but he's teaching it
in portuguese in brazil to small
business owners
that differentiating factor is what's
going to allow him to succeed
because even though there are people
that are teaching youtube and teaching
video and teaching all those things
he's different because of his culture
because of his background and because of
his language so i just want you
if you're watching right now to think
about what makes you different
how can you bring your own spin to
youtube how can you
help people where they are with what
they need help with because you're an
entrepreneur
you're a problem solver and you were
created in the experiences that you have
in the body that you're in in the voice
that you have to bring that to the world
so i just want to encourage you that if
you're feeling like
man i just don't really know what to do
and i'm making all these mistakes
just keep going because we're here to
help i love it well heather i know we
need to land the plane
but here's what we have to do nilo farr
was so wanting to talk to you and i just
want to remind people listen
uh i think we'll be able to take one
more quick question um we still have
some prep to do heather
is at the beginning of this watch the
replay uh because it will be up on the
think marketing
channel she shared three tips she's
sharing seven of them tonight so make
sure you're registered
for the youtube influence challenge it's
happening in a facebook group and
you can get all the details at
tubeinfluence.com we've got
like 10 more sessions to go heather's
going to be doing sessions myself i'm
doing sessions tony on the team is doing
the quick tip of the day
alina chris jordan the whole team's in
the comments helping omar and nolan
are answering questions about tech it's
amazing it's all happening right now
we're in the middle of it so if you
haven't
jumped in yet go to tubeinfluence.com to
jump in but
nilofar heather was talking in the
private chat here on stream
yard and saying she really wanted to
connect with you
so nilo thank you so much for coming on
where are you watching from and what's
your channel all about
hi sean hi heather how are you oh god
i'm so excited
welcome to the show where are you
watching from i'm watching from new
jersey
parsippany new jersey what part
parsippany
new york city burlington
okay what i was i was in the armpit
i lived in the armpit of new jersey
that's what it's called okay
okay i shipped it to new jersey from
india
like two years ago so i am not very sure
about everything but i still know new
jersey and new york very well
yes well welcome to the us and uh it's
been two years already
and it's been two years since i'm
following think media and i love
sean and you and nolan i love nolan's
videos about imovie and all the starter
things and i just love your channel i'm
so excited
so much wow how can we help you today
what question do you have for us
uh yeah so i started my channel around
four months ago and i was doing
vlog style oh my god my channel is on
the screen
okay so i was doing vlog style videos
and i
i was looking at other people who were
making blogs and getting millions of
views like i am eating this i am going
there
i thought i'll also make that like
productive day in quarantine something
like that
but then i saw that i am not getting
views and all the big youtubers say that
you should make
searchable content first when you are in
the beginning portion of your
channel so i started making searchable
contents and i found keywords using
vidiq
and tubebuddy but still i'm not getting
many views i get high scoring keywords
and everything so
i don't know and still i don't know what
niche i am in i'm just finding keywords
whatever high scoring keywords i can get
and i'm just making a video on that
there is not a particular niche i am in
sometimes i think i am
lifestyle sometimes i think it's beauty
i don't know what i am
so it's very confusing i just need help
figuring out a niche because i'm not an
expert at anything i feel like an
imposter
giving advice if i am not an expert i
don't know
how to figure that out wow i uh
first off i just want to honor you and
say congratulations on getting started
because that actually is the hardest
part and i just want to say
that no matter if you're getting views
or not you are building
the muscles of being a creator so
i think a lot of times we get into
youtube and we're like why am i not
getting a million views on things right
but first off we have to build the
muscle
of being a content creator and that's
what you're doing you're in this year
this two years of experimenting
and sometimes we pass over that we think
that
we uh we think that we can get to the
to the winning line without running the
race
and so you're just in this race right
now and that is
amazing so i first want to honor you for
that there's a couple things that you
said that i really want to make you
unpack a little bit
the first thing you said was you're
making content you don't know what niche
you're in because you don't feel like
maybe an expert in something
so i want to reframe that for you
another word that i want you to use
is i want you to use best friend i want
you to use
big sister i want you to use leader
or guide because sometimes when we think
about the word
expert we think we need to have letters
behind our name that we need to have a
degree that we've studied it for a
decade right
but i'll bet that there is something
that you're really passionate about
i'll bet that there's something that
when your friends come over
they're like oh my gosh she's talking
about this all the time she just
like it's just who you are you just
there's certain things that we have that
we just
love so tell me about some things that
you really just love to do what are some
things you love to do
what do i love i love so many things i
love eating i love shopping i love
like people always right now it doesn't
look like it but people always
compliment me on the makeup that i do
and on the clothes that i wear
so yeah my friends keep telling me you
should make makeup videos
but that niche is already so crowded so
i don't think i can break into that
uh that is why i'm not very sure about
it
yeah and you're right makeup is a very
crowded niche
but it doesn't mean if that's your
passion if that's what you want to do
that could be something now are you a
part of the youtube influence challenge
did you sign up for the challenge okay
yes and and then sean posted what is
your niche
uh there was a post and i wrote i don't
know and everyone was liking that
comment i felt so embarrassed
no it's because yeah resonates with
people in the challenge so
last night's session if you if did you i
don't know if you watched it but i'll
just tell you a little bit about it last
night's session that sean did
in the free youtube influence challenge
he talked about this exact thing how do
you figure out what your thing is
because figuring out what your thing is
is one of the things that holds so many
people back
and like i said at the beginning you're
already making content so you are so
close to like
figuring out what the it thing is and so
i recommend definitely go back and watch
the session from last night sean
talked about the three p's that can lead
you to figuring out what your
one thing is now here's one thing i
recommend
i want you to take some time and i want
you to figure out
who you are because right now you're
making a lot of content
that um that may not be where you're
going to end up
so here's what i want you to do i want
you to actually take out a journal and
say
what am i good at because you said
something at the beginning where you
said i'm not an expert i'm not really
good at anything
i think that's a lie i think it's a lie
i think you do have gifts and talents i
think that you
do have things that you are really good
at i think that you have helped people
in your past
and i think that sometimes stepping out
into those things can feel a little
scary but i want to tell you that you do
have things that you are good at
and you do have things that you could
help people with
but we sometimes like to block it
because we're like well what if i'm not
actually the best
at it and here's what's so good about
youtube you don't actually have to be
the best at it
you just have to be the person that
connects with someone and helps them get
a result you're a problem solver so i
want you to shift in your mindset and i
want you to start journaling about
what am i good at what do i do well at
uh what can i help people with i want
you to walk through this exercise
every day for the next seven days
because i think some of the pieces that
are going to help get you an unlock and
a breakthrough
is actually building up the confidence
to know that you are good at something
that you could help someone with
something and that you have value to
bring to youtube
that will eventually start to break
through and get views and right now i
don't want you to care about the numbers
i want you to do the things you've
learned to do you've learned about
keyword research right you know about
keyword research
you've learned that you need to make
searchable content
so what you're going to do is you're
going to go on this journey where you're
going to figure out what can i help
people with what is the thing that you
could help people with what are you
skilled at what are you proficient at
what's something you've worked on for
the last 10 years it could be anything
but really thinking and diving into who
you are
will start to help you figure out oh
that's actually my thing
so if it's makeup let it be makeup
makeup is a huge niche and there is a
lot of money to be made in makeup
but just because other people are doing
it should be actually
a freedom thing because you're like wow
people are making a full-time living
making makeup videos about eyeliner
that was not like can we go back to a
decade ago
that was not a job okay
that was not a job to be like i'm gonna
review this lip gloss today
and literally get like a million views
on a lip gloss video that was not
something a decade ago
so my challenge to you
during this challenge okay is to figure
out what it is you are good at i want
you to go back into it
last night's video re-watch it again
walk through that exercise
of profit proficiency and passion
and i want you to journal through that
because sometimes the breakthrough isn't
going to come in an instant
it's going to take a little bit of
self-work to get to the point where
you're like ah
that's the thing i didn't know that my
thing was going to be digital
advertising i didn't know i was going to
make ads
that would make millions of dollars for
people until i was like wow
i'm i actually i actually like digital
advertising i didn't even know i was
like
i want to help peop i want to just help
people and i remember
a coach of mine one of my mentors said
great
how how great you want to help people
but how you have to someone has to be
like oh that's heather
she can help me do x they're gonna be
like oh that's sean
he can help me with a camera so that's
what we need to get you at does that
make sense
yeah yeah uh i i also have another
confusion and let me just get it out as
long as i have you uh people say that
you should upload your videos at the
time when your target audience is
uh awake so like i am i am an indian and
i am living in the u.s
but when i see my analytics the half 50
audience is from u.s and 50 is from
india so what time should i
upload because when it's day here it's
night in india and when it's day there
it's night here
so what should be the exact time to
upload so that both the audiences can
you know get to it i love that question
i love that question so much
but i want you to just upload
i want so what time when do you want to
upload i want you to go there first
because here's the thing
you're asking the question when you look
at a to z
on how to become successful on youtube
you're asking
the question that's at an m level i need
you to be at a b
i need you to think i need to figure out
what my content is i need to make great
content
i want you to maybe experiment with
posting and that will help you get to
to figuring out when the best time is
but if you have half the audience in
india and half the audience in
in uh the us just pick one just pick
be like you know what i'm gonna post it
when my u.s uh
audience is waking up that's what i'm
gonna post at 6 a.m
every tuesday is when i'm going to post
my videos and just commit to that for a
while
and then really start to dive into what
type of content you're creating who
are you and who do you serve what
problems do you solve
and then over time you'll start to see
more and more of the analytics it'll
start to grow
and then you can shift on when you're
posting but
sometimes we're starting to go deeper
into the things that aren't actually
relevant yet i need you to get back to
who am i
what content am i creating and how can i
actually help people and then
you're you're gonna you're gonna you're
going to win you're going to win if you
just keep at this okay
okay awesome thank you so much i got the
show today i'm so
excited for you to be inside the youtube
influence challenge and let's stay
connected on social too okay are you
already honest
thank you for letting me speak here yes
thank you swan thank you heather
i love you guys hey we appreciate you so
much thanks so much for coming on
yeah thank you wow what an
epic day think marketing q a show
coming at you heather just bring in some
actionable and encouraging
uh motivation there someone said heather
how do i get a motivational call from
heather every day
and like maybe we got to figure that out
but um we're working on
john don't give away our secrets they
can't know about the cool mixtapes that
we're making
projects man stuff that we're cooking up
so many different ideas and i'm sure you
can relate to that
constantly having lots of ideas look if
you love this energy
and you want to uh keep building
momentum
um we're actually in just a couple hours
at the time of recording this live
we heather's going to be live along with
melissa tony and i
for the next session of the youtube
influence challenge but it's also going
to be happening over the next few days
if you're watching this video at some
distant time in the future
go to tubeinfluence.com and you can
always get on the waiting list or be a
part of the next one as
well and so if you haven't signed up yet
make sure to get there
because we're going to be doing more q a
we're going to be doing
more training we have lots of actionable
strategies i saw someone say
you know every niche is crowded and
there's no doubt about it
but when i think about the fact of
things being crowded
i love thinking about coffee right come
on rise and grind
and the reality is is there's coffee
everywhere and i grew up in seattle and
i remember when the first starbucks
was launched my dad used to take me to
get coffee beans at the first
uh starbucks and now years later they've
taken over the world
and it's one of the most influential
coffee branches the question is back
when they started
was just nobody else making coffee no
that's absurd of course people are
making coffee
mcdonald's was serving it pete's coffee
was serving it
seattle's best local coffee shops
espresso stands everywhere
but starbucks came in they found their
place in the market they implemented a
strategy they built one store at a time
one cup of coffee at a time and now
they're a brand of what we know today
what's crazy
is my friend uh started a coffee shop in
seattle and i'm like dude there's
already starbucks and there's already
all kinds of other coffee shops but he's
in a local area and here's the point
people love drinking coffee can i get an
amen
people have all different types of
preferences of coffee hey what's your
favorite kind of coffee are you a dunkin
donuts person or a mcdonald's person
a starbucks person or are you like a
hipster coffee shop
foam art like you know if the beans are
not single origin roasted to perfection
then i send it back you know what i mean
like what kind of coffee person are you
or maybe you're a tea or something else
a lot of people drink coffee and here's
the thing friends there's over two
billion people
on youtube right now a new article was
released that over half the world is on
social media now
not half the people on the internet half
of humans are on social media right
now and so we can look at the size of
the mountain the challenges and for sure
there are challenges ahead
in growing your influence on youtube but
that's the point of this youtube
challenge is to challenge you to get out
of your comfort zone to get committed
to implement strategies that work and to
take massive action and so join us link
in the description below
link in the facebook comments uh cat's a
hipster coffee drinker
suzanne is a diy coffee maker but where
do you get your beans though suzanne
that's the question i mean i was getting
some local
local las vegas vesta coffee it cost
so much money for one bag of coffee just
for beans because they're so
hipster and local you know i get mine
i get mine at costco sean folgers costco
the big thing omar hates it so much
because he's like your beans are getting
dr
your grounds are and it comes
pre-grounded i bet he does yeah see we
we get a whole bean we only grind it
right before
you know frills is 16 percent three
months three months sean is how long
that
those grounds sit in my cupboard that's
so funny machu
yeah like i looked at the expiry you
remember my instagram store i was in
washington i was aghast
i pulled off beans off the and i was
like i can't believe they were roasted
and that's only for people who care that
they were roasted
you know whatever but uh we got
cappuccino and regular from machu hey
thanks so much french press come on cat
i'm doing the aeropress
right now and uh oh melissa the healthy
one just kidding but like green juice no
coffee
we are also green juice lovers ourselves
thank you so much for being here melissa
hey uh we appreciate you so much um hit
like if you got value and maybe share
the replay of this
with somebody and then join us in the
youtube influence challenge because it's
going to be amazing heather land the
plane
um with uh i don't know call to action
to something else and um
and then we'll see people in the next
episode definitely if you are not
subscribed to the think marketing
podcast
right now is the time to hit that red
subscribe button and you'll be notified
every time we go live for the think
marketing q a
as well as when the weekly podcast drops
if you want to watch another video you
can click the one that's on the screen
right now and we'll catch it in the next
video